>> THANK YOU, JESSE.
>> Jesse: SO FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN MORE THAN A YEAR JOE BIDEN IS
MAKING BORDER SECURITY IS TOP
PRIORITY NOT OUR SOUTHERN BORDER
WHICH HAS BECOME A PLAYGROUND
FOR DRUG SMUGGLING CARTELS BUT
THE BORDER OF RUSSIA AND
UKRAINE.
HE CARES SO MUCH ABOUT RUSSIA'S
BORDER AGGRESSION HE SENT HIS
TWO BEST PEOPLE FOR EUROPE THERE
TO GET THINGS UNDER CONTROL.
SECRETARY OF STATE TONY BLINKEN
WHO MANAGED TO DETONATE KABUL
WHILE VACATIONS IN THE HAMPTONS
THIS SEPTEMBER, AND VICE
PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS, WHO IS
STILL ON THE HUNT FOR THE ROOT
CAUSES OF HER BAD POLL NUMBERS.
SHE DIDN'T FIND THEM IN MUNICH
THIS WEEKEND BUT SHE DID TELL
AMERICANS BUCKLE UP.
THE PRICE OF GAS IS ABOUT TO GET
A WHOLE LOT MORE EXPENSIVE.
>> WHEN AMERICA STANDS FOR HER
PRINCIPLES, AND ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT WE HOLD DEAR, UM, IT
REQUIRES SOME TIMES FOR US TO
PUT OURSELVES OUT THERE IN A WAY
THAT MAYBE WE WILL INCUR SOME
COST.
AND IN THIS SITUATION, THAT MAY
RELATE TO ENERGY COST.
>> Jesse: SO THEY WAITED ABOUT
TWO MONTHS TO TROT HARRIS OUT IN
GERMANY WITH A MASK ON TO SAY
YEAH, THIS SITUATION, UKRAINE,
GOING TO MAKE GAS MORE
EXPENSIVE.
WE ARE GOING TO SEE A LOT MORE
PAIN AT THE PUMP.
ALL IN EXCHANGE FOR AMERICA
STANDING UP TO ITS PRINCIPLES.
AND THERE IS NO SIGN THAT THIS
IS GETTING ANY BETTER SINCE THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION QUIETLY
HALTED JUST A COUPLE DAYS AGO
NEW OIL DRILLING ON FEDERAL
LAND.
QUAY WOULD THEY DO THAT IF
INCOME PRICES ARE ABOUT TO
SKYROCKET BECAUSE OF UKRAINE?
WHY WOULD THEY DO THAT?
THEY ARE MAKING THEIR MESSAGE
CLEAR, UKRAINE'S PROBLEMS ARE
WORTH MORE THAN YOUR PROBLEM.
THE QUESTION IS, CAN THEY HANDLE
TWO CRISES AT ONCE?
AND CAN THEY WALK AND CHEW GUM
AT THE SAME TIME?
>> WE OUGHT TO BE ABLE THAT OLD
EXPRESS OF WALK AND CHEW GUM AT
THE SAME TIME.
>> PRESIDENT CAN WALK AND CHEW
GUM AT THE SAME TIME.
>> WE OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO WALK
AND CHEW GUM AT THE SAME TIME.
>> Jesse: CAN YOU, GENTLEMEN?
AND WHY UKRAINE?
WHY NOW?
THAT WAS JOE CHEWING GUM WHEN HE
WAS GOING UP THE STAIRS.
IF EASTERN EUROPE'S INDEPENDENCE
WAS SO CRITICAL TO OUR
PRINCIPLES, MAYBE WE WOULDN'T
HAVE SPENT THREE DECADES OF
FOREIGN POLICY TRYING TO EXPAND
NATO INTO FORMER SOVIET
TERRITORIES.
REMEMBER, JOE WAS ON THE FRONT
LINES OF THAT NOT TOO LONG AGO.
FOR 40 YEARS, THE UNITED STATES
LOUDLY PROCLAIMED ITS SOLIDARITY
WITH THE CAPTIVE NATIONS OF
CENTRAL AND EASTERN EUROPE WHO
WERE UNDER THE HEEL OF THE
COMMUNIST OPPRESSOR.
NOW THAT MOST OF THEM HAVE CAST
OFF THEIR SHACKLES, IT'S OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO LIVE UP TO OUR
PLEDGES TO READMIT THEM INTO THE
WEST THROUGH NATO.
>> Jesse: SO, FOR DECADES BIDEN
AND EVERYBODY HAS PUSHED,
PUSHED, PUSHED NATO EXPANSION,
NATO EXPANSION, RUSSIA SAYS NO,
NO, NO THAT'S A THREAT AND HERE
WE ARE IN UKRAINE.
THIS IS WHERE WE ARE.
THE D.C. SWAMP HAD THEIR HISTORY
OF SCREWING OVER UKRAINE.
BILL CLINTON COERCED UKRAINE TO
GIVE UP ITS NUKES BACK IN THE
1990s.
PUTIN WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN
INVADING NOW IF UKRAINE HAD
NUKES.
TRUST ME.
LET'S NOT FORGET THE 2014 COUP
IN UKRAINE WHERE BARACK AND JOE
BIDEN HAD A LITTLE HAND IN
REPLACING THAT PRO-RUSSIAN
ELECTED PRESIDENT.
NOW WHAT?
SO, DOES D.C. EVEN CARE ABOUT
WHAT'S REALLY GOING ON IN
UKRAINE LIKE THEY SAY THEY DO?
IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE IT.
IT SEEMED LIKE THIS IS JUST ONE
BIG DISTRACTION.
FOR EVERYBODY IN WASHINGTON.
MAYBE THEY WILL MAKE A QUICK
DIME OVER THIS LIKE THEY HAVE
BEEN.
PLACE HAS BEEN A PIGGY BANK FOR
WASHINGTON ESTABLISHMENT TYPES.
THEY ARE JUST GOING T